laughs
a good humored meeting between Rishi
sunak and Emmanuel macron of France at
the cop 27 climate Summit in Egypt but
behind the smiles this is a prime
minister working to regain credibility
after initially saying he wasn't even
going to turn up
we can turn our struggle against climate
change into a global mission for new
jobs and clean growth
there really is room for hope
together
let us fulfill it do you feel that you
might be undermining the government's
position by being here very very
important to deliver on what we did it
in Glasgow cop 26. but former prime
minister Boris Johnson host of the
previous cop has a slightly different
take slipping away I'm the spirit of
Glasgow that's what I'm doing yeah I'm
the spirit of Glasgow cop 26 and it's
incredible to think how much has changed
since that last cop and to be frank how
much damage has been done
in just one year
unfortunately for those trying to make
progress here he's right the reality is
that despite all the effort being made
here things are going in the wrong
direction last year carbon emissions
Rose to their highest ever levels and
one UN agency says there's currently no
credible pathway in place to limit
global warming to 1.5 degrees
hence the U.N secretary General's
pessimistic tone we are in the fight of
our lives and we are losing
we are on a highway to climate hell with
our foot still on the accelerator
Russia Bears its share of the blame for
this not that it will take any
responsibility you have reduced the
supply of energy to Europe and you are
driving an energy crisis we haven't
heard any Acquisitions of Russia that
our country is to blame for this energy
crisis and uh we would like to notice
that the energy Crisis began long before
the current military operation
but the major issue is cash and not
enough of it to help countries like
flood ravaged Pakistan who are suffering
from climate-driven disasters
in my country millions of people
are going into winter without the
shelter or livelihood the latest
estimates
have calculated loss in damage at 30
billion dollars are you feeling that
there's still real Anger from developing
nations that wealthy nations are not
doing enough sure I think
it's understandable
and you're here to address that we
certainly are
whether it will be enough will Define
this Summit for developing nations it
has become a matter of trust and of
survival